[音楽]
ブーブーおっきいですよ
ですね元気だね
代表なんですけども今からくる馬鹿なユーチューバーたちは全員
鬼ごっこすると思っていますあーこればっかですね
俺がそんな商法でほどするわけでずっとでもうみんなは鬼ごっこする気満々で眉が今が
良い年も彼が来るわけですけどなぁ
んですけども実はそれが嘘ぶってる
今からちゃんと茶のミーティングをして僕の多くにもするんですけども
あの打球にもどって来る途中の縁があるんですけどもその道で突然100人のゾンビに
追いかけられるドッキリでございますごいいですねー
はぁはぁそれなんか3つじゃなくてもよるなんでバックアップする
普通にコインと思うんですよそんな中彼らはどんなリアクションができるのか
泊まりはれて見ていきます予定でクリエイターさんがブッチ
雪やひょうちゃんだとの4人を選んでおりますすっごくオールスターズね結構ピュッ
reaction to do
2バージョンなので皆さんで100人のゾンビで多いかけられる様を楽しんでいき
ましょう
ださっすぐドッキリやっていきましょうね by 行為
ポッ姓に版っていうゲームが気
またの内山パラさんにそのオープンが気に入って一つずつおよびするのでこういったと
いうわけで今隠れております我々は
ターゲット枚冊を待つ
一緒だい
というわけで最初のターゲットはきょうちゃんでございます
レーザー通すかにと思います
ちゃんの略称が
嫌ですよね
ゾンビ注がいきます
ん
プレリー
ここ
[音楽]
ぶって意
これ共産はあっはあっ
[拍手]
[音楽]
あ時におらああああ
ああいや本当に俺隅っこはでしたか
真ん中歩いてたらさぁあったあったけど
[音楽]
ブーブーてください
ブーブーやっどうでした
もうカメラねいやまあ見てなっアーマー結局いれば動けるって事ああっにょっちで
ございますよ
gex んだよねそうするねあとあいつは馬鹿なんで多分真ん中歩くと思うんだ
フィーリアクションが期待できると思いますご覧ください
頑張った彼
そろそろ入っています
うん
on
ん
裏 b
go
1ん
ああああああ
うぁああああああああああ
良い形だ
あえっとやっぱり宇宙バナー
めっちゃ式降ってる
無駄に行くから見ていきますよ
ていました
ドッキリさーああバッハとんでもないことしたらまた
というわけで束ね100人に突然を追いかけられると聞いてございましたね
はい
えっ
いやすごいいっぱいいるアッ同じでもらったやれよえええええええ
こんばんは2階こんばんはこんばんは
あ
あっ配置を挙げて次のターゲットは徹夜でございます
どーすかねぇ
難しいですね読めないんだよね未知数すぎるからはただなんかあんまり寝てツヤがとっ
きーに引っかかるっていうのをあまり見ないかなあズー
ちょっと本当に前世に反応が楽しみでございます果たして彼は
どうするのでしょうか一つ
これやー
地獄に行った時ほどしてやるよ
[音楽]
繰り返していた
うん
ん
ああああああ
フェリー
複合
[音楽]
djif
ああああああ
食べません
あっはぁ
nd
[音楽]
ナギを得すごい
一緒に行くかうーん
[音楽]
ん
やっぱりを減って0
ドッキリ大成功デー
[音楽]
もうはいそういうわけで急に姓確認に追いかけられたらどうするのが時に出た
何だろうなこの感じでも先発弱凄かったよ死ぬと思って
4つで早かったよねなんですね腕だしかなかったいやもうマジ8割くらいいただけたん
で2人を麻布
うん
うんなかなかいいタイムでした言いたい事があるんねはい打てるんあ
オリー
改や謝礼はで a 1をにもこうしませんウソでしょ
それからねこれ談春犯人フルバックなってるよ
何気ない感じで是非はい完璧な感じ
いや音楽家さっき強かったよみんな歌っはいいだけ
ブーブー僕ねちゃいいと思って略称パティ対応してます
全米とるさん配布
ブーバーそろそろ何度見ていきましょう
どうぞ
これ0
on
ガーリッ
[音楽]
melo でーっ
多いなぁ
掴めましたやれございますてってれー
voodoo
[音楽]
me
心臓止まるかと思って本当に打っていく
よくあの人数集まってねそれではまた会いたいよ
4つけっだめだぜ動くなんですわけねーよぷっ
ねええええ
めっちゃやりたかったらあっはいというわけでこちらの墓発にドッキリを仕掛けてみ
ましたーーー
ブーバーカードじゃあ誰がばえっ
ブーブー夏んでいただけたというわけですねああ幸せがございます多いこのたびなんと
dmm ゲームズさんより鋼鉄上の姓
りなんというゲームがリリースされましたーーー
これは特急じゃないこれでぽかーんファースト a 3年前にですね
鋼鉄上のカバネルというアニメがやっておりましてこの事全部見たんですけども
なんと来年の春に植え後決戦という劇場版の windows の頭の続きが
in 上映されますうわあああっ
ブーブーね鋼鉄場も姓リット
来年春にある映画の間のものがてぃ以下にょ入ってロスアプリの中にもうこちら
[音楽]
ブーバー好調の姓リーダー動画概要欄からだろすっぜひソロ村で見てください
てい
[音楽]
それでは皆さんと別れの挨拶をしましょうばいばー
ああああああ
[音楽]
me
あっはぁ
nome
[音楽]